she's leaving the show
um I don't know if you heard and because
she got caught stealing Band-Aids from
the set they uh
finally they caught her Patrick Dempsey
AKA mcdream McDreamy thinks he knows the
real reason why Ellen pompeo's leaving
Gray's Anatomy that was a very special
bond that it was just there was a magic
to our connection the actor who played
Ellen's on-screen husband Derek Shepard
on the medical drama until 2015 and
briefly returned in 2021 during dream
sequences
couldn't help but joke with Jimmy Kimmel
about Ellen seemingly hanging up her
scrubs for good because she got caught
stealing Band-Aids from the set they uh
really
finally they caught her yeah and they
had the sadly had the letter go uh but
uh imagine what she would have in her
house now from oh man if I ever get a
whole hospital I'm headed right there
yeah for sure do you have this yeah I
need it okay so stealing Band-Aids isn't
exactly the reason fans of the
long-running series know the actress
previously announced she'd be taking a
reduced role in season 19. I mean I've
been trying to get away for years
um and on Thursday Alan hinted her time
on the show is close to the end she
wrote alongside this photo quote I am
eternally grateful and humbled by the
love and support you have all shown me
Meredith gray and the show for 19
Seasons this isn't your first time on
the roller coaster you know the show
must go on and I'll definitely be back
to visit it's still Grace she's still
there in spirit and that's the house
that gray built yeah so she's always
there looming she just has to step away
for a little bit Gray's Anatomy Creator
Shonda Rhimes shared a heartfelt
response to Ellen's post
quote what a wild ride these past 19
seasons have been none of it could have
been possible without the incomparable
Ellen Pompeo the one and only Meredith
gray this isn't a good buy it's a see
you later while there are so many other
characters that you fall in love with I
think that for me I have anchored the
writing around the evolution of that
character so for me I wanted her to be
there Ellen's message comes nearly a
week after the dramatic season 19 fall
finale when Meredith's house that she
shared with Derek went up in flames
it's our house man all right let it
through all right it's okay and
everyone's find the kids are right here
what happened
oh we were upstairs and lightning struck
the house
I mean I guess you know
um Hey listen it's drama yeah we need
drama but there's still some good news
Ellen remains an executive producer plus
fans will see mayor two more times this
season she's set to appear in the winter
premiere February 23rd on ABC it's been
a lot
[Music]
listen the show speaks to a lot of
people and the young people love the
show it's inspired so many generations
of healthcare workers so I think for for
the young people it's a really good
piece of content and we're going to try
to keep it going for the young people
not necessarily with me but you know to
keep it going beyond me
foreign